では よろしくお願いします
今日はこの忙しいということをについてお話しさせていただきます
お釈迦様のお話になりますから
この別にこの個人的にあれこれということではなくて
忙しいという そのことが何の意味するのかというね
ちょっとしたもう学校で勉強するような感じのものになります
で あの 2種類いるんですよ
人間の中で まあ忙しいと結構楽しく言う人と
もう忙しいやとという文句を言う人っていうのは 2種類いるんです
まあ結構忙しいんだよと
すごい楽しみで言ってる人もいるんです
まあ同じこと もう忙しいということでも
もう嫌で言ってる人もいます
で 今日はその 2種類の中で
この 2番目 この嫌で文句を言う人のケースを考えてみたいんです
忙しいってことは 喜んでいる人っていうのは
あの まあただもうなかなかうまくいってるんだという意味で
あの 何も仕事もなくて
やることもなくて ただまあといるわけじゃなくて
無駄に時間なくなってるわけじゃなくて
適切に時間を使っているということで使用しているということで
また本人はそれなりに充実はしている
ですから まあ忙しいということは喜んでいる人
言ってる人のケースはここであまり分析はしません
それで この忙しいということは
仏教的に分析すると これはこの時間と時間の流れと自分の生き方の組み合わせなんです
時間の流れがあります
それで自分の生き方があります
どちらでも流れいくんですよ
そこでうまく合ってるのかないかということで
それどちらかする 特に自分が遅くなっちゃうと
もうそれが忙しいってことなんです
だって外の世界の時間に
時間に自分が合わせなくちゃいけない
普段は足が遅い これで大変なことになりますね
だからこの我々はどうやってこの時間と自分の生き方っていうのを組み合わせるのかという大変な難しいテーマにはなりますけども
私にはどうすることもできないんです
それが なぜかというと
忙しい だって言っただけでいいがないんですよ
これは仏教的に見ると
これは個人の生き方の流れと世界の時間の流れという
そのかみ合わせがうまくいっていないということで
はい だいたいこの内容はそんなに簡単なので
そんなに難しいものではございませんので
淡々と読み上げることだけにします
で 忙しい なぜ忙しいということでね
これは社会の立場から言うと
こういうことを言えますよ
一番は仕事多すぎ もう多すぎんだからもうやりきれないんですね
で 別にやりたいこともあるのにとかね
まあ多すぎってわけじゃないんだけど
もう自分やってる仕事以外何かやりたいことはあるんですよ
あるんだけど 仕事のせいでできないんですね
それで忙しさ感じちゃうんですね
3番目は 与えられた仕事を時間内で終わらない
自分に与えられた仕事はありますけど
それは全然時間内で終了することはできないんですね
それで人がすごい忙しいということを感じちゃうんですね
余裕は感じないんですね
仕事に時間がかかりすぎ
逆に自分が仕事を別に時間内で終わらないわけじゃないんだけど
あれこれで時間がかかってしまうんですね
その時も忙しいと言ってしまうんですよ
現代社会では複雑 複数のことを行わないと生きていられないと
まあそういう風に言ってる人もいるんですよ
もう今の世界ではあれとこれといろんなことをやっておかないと
もう生きていられないんだよと
だから忙しいんだよという人もいる
それで ６番目 仕事に余裕があると収入の余裕がなくなる
これも一つの問題で 仕事に余裕があるということは
収入にの余裕がなくなっちゃうんですね
だから収入には余裕があってほしいでしょうし
ですから もうしょうがなく
もう忙しくするしかないんです
はい ７番目 忙しくないと落ち着かない人もいるんですよ
無茶忙しく生きていないとなかなか落ち着かない
イライラする人間もいる
だからわざと忙しくするんです ８
番目は暇な自分が惨めだと思う
なんか暇があると なんて惨めです
みんな一生懸命頑張っているのにとかね
私のはやることないんだとか
そこが惨めに感じちゃうんですね
惨めに感じたくない人々は
なんとかくだらないことをでもして忙しくするんです ９
番目は 社会が周りが強引に仕事を押し付けている
自分ではやりたくないんだけど
社会が周りの人はあれやってください
これやってくださいと言われるわ
言われるわ 強引すぎ どうしてもやらなくちゃいけないし
だから忙しいんだと 自分ではやりたくないんですけどね
という状態もあります
10番目 義務 義理 責任がある
まあ暇があってもいいんだけど
私にはいろいろ義務がありますし
義理もあるし いろいろ責任もあるんだからね
まあ放って置いてられませんよという人もいるんでしょうね
世の中で  11追い抜かれたくない
自分がのんびりしちゃうとどうなるかというと
自分がもう追い越されちゃうんですよ
これは嫌なんですよ だからわざと忙しくするんです
12番目  成功したい 失敗はしたくない
とにかく人生は成功 成功したい
失敗したくない だからのんびりはいられないということなんです
そういう 12種類の理由がありまして
人間が忙しいんです はい
次に行きます それで まあ 1日のまあほんのちょっとの
まあまあ いい加減な説明ですけどね
一番の仕事が多すぎという場合は
どういうふうに分析すればよろしいでしょうかと
ある時間内で完了できないほど仕事がある場合
例えばたくさん仕事を頼まれちゃって
こんなこの時間内では終わらないんだよという場合ありますよ
大体経験ある方々いると思いますよ
その人は仕事を減らすしかないんですよ
忙しいと文句言うんじゃなくて
これこれできませんよと
他頼んでくださいと堂々と言わなきゃいけないのにね
自分にこなせない分をカットしてないことにする
気楽になりますよ ただもう上からもうこれあれ
これこれもやってください
あれもやってくださいと
今日中にやってくださいと言うと
はいはい わかりました
はいはい わかりましたという人はもう失敗しますよ
はいはい わかりましたではなくて
これぐらいこれぐらいしかできませんよと
他返して持って帰ってくださいと
他頼んでくださいと あるいは今日中だったらもうこれぐらい仕事できるんだから
どちらやればいいかと
あんた決めてくださいと言うしかないんですよ
して 持っていかれた仕事は自分にとってはない
それは私の仕事ではありません
とカットするとすごい気が楽になるんですよ
気分よく自分の仕事はできるんですね
自分 またケースがある
自分に能力がない スピードが遅い場合はね
仕事多すぎじゃなくて
自分に能力がないんです
自分のスピードが遅いんですね
その場合 どうすればいいかというと
一番能力を向上するほかないでしょ
答えは あるいはスピードが遅いということは
仕事が合ってないかも
ですから 合った仕事をする
いちいち文句言うんじゃなくて
あるいはできれば仕事を減らしてもらう
私はちょっと遅いんだから
ここまではできませんだから減らしてちょうだいと
そうすると同時に収入も減るということも覚えておかなくちゃいけないんです
例えば 1個終わったら
まあもう 500円やというと
まあ 1 日 まあ例えば 100個仕事をできれば
それぐらい500掛ける 100でしょうに
やっぱり 1 日 100 はできませんやと
まあせいぜい 60 やと言ったら
もう 500 かける 60 でしょ
収入は だから残る 40 はできないんだから
それは返す しょうがないんです
それ嫌だったら 収入が減るのは嫌だったら
もう能力向上するか 別な仕事をするかということしか答えがないんです
それで私はこの忙しいということで文句言ってる人々はどうすればいいかという
まあ答えすると出してるんです
説明なしに はい 次 2番目のポイントの場合は
別にやりたいこともあるのにという場合はね
その説明はね いつも 混乱ですか？混乱ですね
そういう人っていうのは
いつも混乱状態でいるんですよ
仕事はするしているんだけど
部分的にやりたいのにね
なんだ もう今これなんでやらなくちゃあかんかとかね
自分に文句言ってるんですよ
別なやりたいこともあって
例えば土曜日はもう競輪競馬に行きたいと決めていたのに
もう会社でもう止まってもらったと
あんた土曜日も仕事をしなさいと言うと
もう忙しいってことを同等に言うんですね
忙しい しかし いややと
もう別なこともやりたいというね
だから混乱状態でいるんですよ
そういう別なことをやりたいのにという人が機嫌が悪いんです
いつでも当たり前ですけどね
悪くて 機嫌が悪くて生きているんですよ
能力も効率も下がる そういう人の場合はよく覚えておいてください
もし仕事中 別なこともやりたいのにという気持ちがあったら
もう自分の能率も仕事の効率も結構下がるんです
失敗もする そこは悪いところで
解決はどちらが必要かは区別するんですよ
別にやりたいこともあることもあるのにではなくて
今やっていることでやりたいこと
どちらがより必要かと区別すればいいでしょうに
どちらも必要だと思われる時
優先順位を考える やっぱり決められませんと
どちらも大事ですよと言ったら
優先順位を考える ということを
例えば会社に行くか 子供が病気で子供の面倒を見るかというね
どちらで優先かというと
ちょっと決められないでしょうに
でも両方できないですね
同じ時間間感覚だから
子供を病院に連れて行かなくちゃいけないしで
自分も仕事に行かなくちゃいけないし
その場合はもう一つカット
優先はどちらか どちらでも大事だと思った人は困りますけど
優先で考えればいいんですよ
それは決められませんよ
まあ病気 子供の病気の状態にもなるし
例えば別に薬なくてもちょっと寝ちゃえば治るんだったら仕事に行くしかないし
そんなもんじゃないんだったら仕事をカットするしかないし
だからその都度その都度優先順位順を決めれば
その問題は解決する あるいはそういう人っていうのは
利他主義で生きることは法則違反なので
自分が社会の一員であることを認識する
別なやりたいことはあるのにと言った人が自我主義なんですね
俺がやりたいことをやりたいという気持ちでいるんですね
でも この世の中で俺がやりたいことだけやって生きていられるはずがないんです
俺という私というものは存在しないんです
我々はただ単なる何車でしたっけ？歯車ですから
社会システムの中で だから他の車と噛み合わせて回すしかないんです
自我があるとそれが困っちゃうんです
だから自我を張ることはできないと
これは自我張っちゃうと
これは法則違反やと崩れますよと
機械の中で一つの車が変な変に回転しちゃうと
それは外しちゃうんです
外して別なものを入れるんです
この部品が故障しているんだと
だから我々も我が自我主義で言っちゃうと
社会からはみ出されるんですよ
あなたは故障品だと 欠陥部品だよと
それでは生きていられないんですね
だからそれが法則違反なんですよ
それも覚えておいた方が
この問題は解決すると思います
はい  3番目に行きます
与えられた仕事を時間内で終わらない場合はどうしようかと
その説明は仕事が多すぎと同じですけどね
だって与えられた仕事を終わらないっていうことは
仕事が多いことと同じですけど
ちょっと違うんですね
時間を無駄にしている
別なことをやっている
調子に乗らない やりたくない仕事という原因があるんです
与えられた仕事は本当は時間内でできますけど
時間を無駄にしている
コーヒー飲んだり それからもうタバコを吸ったり
それからちょこちょこと新聞を読んだり
あれこれやでやっているんです
それでも間に合わなくなっちゃうんですね
あるいはもう別な何かやってるんです
例えば まあ授業中なのに
自分がもう机の下で隠れて漫画読んでるとかね
そんな感じで何か別なことをやっている
そうするとなかなか間に合わなくなったり
あるいは仕事を調子に乗らない
調子に乗るということは
やっぱり仕事をやる場合は
すぐそこに乗って徹底的にやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
特に能力のない人々は
与えられた仕事にじっとかかっていかないとできないんです
能力なければないほど
みんないい加減で なんとかなんとかもう早く終わろうとするんで
できるわけないんですよ
だからまあ能力ある人は存分に仕事をしますけど
その能力っていうことは
この仕事にどれぐらいの集中力でかかるかっていうことなんです
あの戦争と同じで じっと行って戦ってかかっていかないと負けちゃうんですよ
ですから この仕事をやっぱり能力ない人もちゃんとすごい調子に乗っちゃうと何とかできますよ
それによって能力は向上するんです
あるいは仕事 これはやりたくないやと
... 思うと 簡単に仕事はありすぎや忙しいだと
何の暇もないんだと 余裕がないと文句を言うんです
だからこれはやりたくない仕事ということで
それでそれなりに自分で考えればいいんです
答えは 仕事に集中すると
やりたくないものでも楽しくなるんです
我々にやりたくない やりたくないという
そう簡単に仕事を選択する自由もないんですよね
自分に子供がいると 私は子供は可愛いんだけど
おむつは変えたくはないんだと
そんなこと言えますかね
ですから このやりたくなくてもやらなくちゃいけない仕事っていうのはいくらでもありますから
調子に乗っちゃえばいいんですよ
上手にやろうではないかと
そうすると やりたくない仕事でも結構楽しくなってしまうんです
時間も無駄にすることもなくなる
それで時間を無駄にするという問題あるでしょ
それもなくなっちゃうんです
だからただ集中すればいいということで
ほとんど解決するんです
集中仕事に これ一生集中じゃないんですよ
その仕事に集中するだけのことで
それからふざけててもいいんです
終わってから それだけで全てのこれは解決するんです
はい 次 仕事に時間がかかりすぎという場合
であまり時間がかかる仕事だったら
忙しい 忙しいと言っちゃうんです
仕事自体自体が複雑 他の原因もあって早く終わらない
時間かかるってことはそういうことなんですよ
仕事は複雑 あるいはいろいろ他の原因も出てくる
例えば仕事してるともう電話電話がかかってくるとかね
応対しなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それでまるっきり別な件だったら
もう頭を混乱しちゃうでしょうし
そんないろいろ別な原因も出てくるって
もう仕事に時間かかっちゃうんですね
その場合はどうすればいいんでしょうかね １
何にでも飛びかかるかかるのではなく
仕事は何かと把握していく
仕事はやるぞではなくて
一気に一発でやりますではなくて
どういう仕事かね？とかね
どういう風にやればよろしいかと
この仕事の内容っていうのを把握してほしいんですよ
把握してからやるかやらないか決めればいいんですね
それから分析してみるんです
だから 常に論理的な思考を生かして仕事をする
仕事をするときでも よくよく論理的に考えるんです
これだからこうなるということで
あ こう こうなっているのはこういうわけであるとかね
それで仕事をしながら
そこから自分もいろいろ学ばなくちゃいけない
で 複雑な仕事でも そうやって内容わかると分析はできます
で いわゆる他の言葉で言えば
仕事は小さな小さな部分に複雑な仕事でもね
まずこれをやります 次にこれをやります
次にこれをやりますと
段取り決めればいいんです
カットして仕事を部分いろいろ部分にカットして
段取りっていうものがありますからね
全部一発でできるわけじゃないんです
料理の場合は まず材料を買う
まず何を調理するか決めることでしょうね
何て言いますか 献立やらリストやらね
それから じゃあどれぐらいの量が必要と決めることで
それから買い物することでしょうし
それで段取りと順番というのがあるんですね
そうすると そのそれぞれの部分だけに集中してやるとうまくいきますよ
別な原因だったらどうしようかと
自分の怠け以外の原因で早く終わらない場合は
忙しいとは言えないんです
自分の怠けで早く終わらない場合は
もうその人は忙しいと言うんですよ
自分に管理できない原因で
今言ったような 例えば全く違う何か電話がかかったけど
それも大変大事なことで
それに行かなくちゃいけない
緊急事態が生じたと まずその緊急なことをしなくちゃいけない
なのに こっちの仕事はまだ終わってないんですよ
それで忙しいとは感じますよ
感じるかも でもその通り感じませんよ
しょうがないやと なんてことか
仕事終わってないんだとは言わないんですよ
その場合は  はい 嫌な気持ちにはならないんで
例えば部屋は散らかっている
片付けて掃除しようかなと思ったところで
もう例えば突然子供が何か事故を起こしちゃって怪我したとすると
その時は突然の出来事だから
すぐ子供を連れてもうどこかに治療所に連れて行く
それで待たせて待たせて待たせ
待たされて待たされて帰ってくると 1 2時なんです
もう部屋は散らかしたままで
はー忙しいとは言わないんですよ
その時は まあまあ それはまあしょうがないと
だから怠けでそうなっちゃうと忙しいと堂々と言んですよ
大体怠ける人っていうのは結構忙しいということを言うんです
はい 次 現代社会では複数のことを行わないと生きていられないという場合はどうしようかと
説明は これは言い訳です
これが単なる言い訳 複数のことをしなきゃ生きていられないというのは
社会適合性に問題があるんです
自分にこの社会に対して適合性があるかないかという
これからダーウィンさんの説をできますけど
この場合は適合性の問題なんです
社会に人間がいる 人間が社会を構成する
それは現代に 現代に関係はありません
時代に関係ありません
社会っていうのは時代に関係ないんですよ
現代社会ではなんで言うんでしょうかね
自分が過去の社会で生きていた経験があるわけではないでしょうに
私がこの社会で生まれて
この社会で年取って この社会で死ぬんでしょうね
この社会は私たちが作っている社会でしょうに
現代社会ではあれこれやらないと生きていられないというのはとんでもない言い訳なんですよ
なんでそういうことに適合性がないんですよ
だからダーウィンさんの論理で言えば
適合性がない人はどうすればいいんですかね
どうなるんですかね 適合性かけると
生存できない 生存できないでしょうに
そこでこの社会から消えるしかないんです
もう自然に消えますけど
適合性に欠けていることを嘘でごまかしている
適合性が低い人は控えて生きることですよ
それ大丈夫です あれもやりたい
これもやりたいとかね
あの人やっていることもやりたい
あの人もやっていることをやりたいではなくて
自分に適合性がないんです
だから控えて自分にできることをやって
命拾いすればいいんです
余計なことをしないで
で これちょっとまあわかりやすくするために
例えばもう若い時はバリバリ元気で頑張ったかもしれませんだけど
70歳になったところで
自分がずっと毎日自分で車を運転して仕事に行ってきたんだと
随分自信があるんだと
言っても 70歳ぐらいになってくると車も多いし
今の車っていうのは随分スピードもあるし
もうまたもう今車と言ったってもほとんど電子機械だからね
これもわけも 自分が古い古い車で乗ってるんだから
何か故障したっても まあそれ修理できるし
しかしこれはもうあの
労働労働に適応性なくなっちゃうと捨てなくちゃあかんでしょ
そうすると自分がもうしょうがなく新車買っちゃったと
買っちゃっても何もできない
もうわからない それで苦労して事故を起こすんじゃなくて
まあいいやと これからまあ控えめで電車で行くぞというふうに控えめればいいんですよ
例えばもうやり方もわからない
もうカーナビなんかつけちゃって
これであれ これ何が押すんでしょうかとか
リモコンで押すとこれ事故起こしちゃうんです
車は動いてるんだからね
あれ これ何でしたっけ？なんとかとかね
あるいはデータインプットができなかったとかね
なんとかとか そんなことだったらやめた方がいいでしょうに
命に関わるものじゃないんだからね
ですから それも適合性がなくなったってことなんで
誰でも年取っていくと適合性がなくなるんです
はい 次 仕事に余裕があると
収入が収入に余裕がなくなるという原因こと
これは経済的な問題ですからね
適切な収入になる仕事を選んでないか
自分が生きるために何が欠かせないのかと知らないで浪費人になっている
それは分析なんですよ
収入も減るんだったら
それは経済的な問題で
私にはどうすることもできない
あるいは自分が自分に適した仕事を選んでないんですよ
まあいい加減に中途半端で仕事を選んだか
もう怠けてもう簡単単純な仕事を選んだか
あるいは威張ってできもしない仕事を選んだか
そのどちらかなんですね
だから 自分に必要な収入に適切な仕事を選ばなくちゃいけないし
あるいは人々はよくいるんですよ
自分にどうしても必要なものは何なのかと
私自身にどうしても必要なものは何なのかとはっきりしない
あれも欲しい これも欲しい
あれも買いたい これも買いたいと
やってるだけで買っては置くんだけど
使ったことはないとかね
そういうことっていうのはよくありますよ
だから このあれもこれもやりたいと思っちゃうと
お金がいくらあっても足らないんですよ
そうすると いくら仕事をしても終わらないんですよ
だから 人間として 自分としても生きるためには欠かせないものは知った方がいいんです
欠かせないものを知らないと
みんな浪費する浪費する人々なんですよ
絶対浪費してはいけないんです
それ答えは 経済は豊かになれなればかな
良いが 個人には解決できないね
これが 経済豊かだったら問題はないんですけど
報酬の良い仕事を選ぶ
に コマーシャルに騙されないこと
コマーシャルに騙されちゃうと
この欠かせないものをわからなくなっちゃうんです
命に生きることに欠かせないものって何なのかということは全くわからなくなっちゃうんです
全部必要と勘違いするんです
これ ひどいんですよ コマーシャルのことは
それから 3番目 節約を習う
節約っていうのはすごい知識的な生き方なんですよ
頭が悪い人は節約できません
ですから 節約という技術を習う
4番目 流行に乗るだけはノーではないと理解する
ただ単に流行に乗ったっていうことは
もう馬鹿者っていう意味なんですよ
何にでも乗っているんだと
それではなくて よく考えて乗るべき流行に乗る
乗ってもどうでもいいことには乗らないというところも必要なんですね
だからいつでも流行に乗ろうとしているんだから
だいたいこの問題は忙しいという問題は出てくるんです
それは解決方法で はい
次に行きます もうちゃんと解決策ありますから
それで覚えておいてください
7番目 忙しくないと落ち着かない人って何なのかと
それで分析は黒い文字で
解決方法は青い文字でいつでも書いているんです
そのパターンで 現代社会ではよく見られる精神不安定の問題
それが これがよく見られます
子供までそうなんですよ
1分でも落ち着かないんです
何かやらないと 何やるかというと
ゲームしかやらないという
で これ精神不安定ということなんです
忙しく振る舞うからといって心は安定するわけではない
そこであれこれとやって忙しくするんですよ
わざと忙しくないと落ち着かない
しかし 忙しくしたんだからといって心は治ったわけじゃないんです
自分が逃げ道を探している
この精神不安定な状態から逃げ道を探している
だから忙しい 忙しいと言いながら
文句言いながら なんとかやって忙しくする
それで答えどうしようかなと
解決方法は情報に無批判的に心を開かないこと
我々 現代社会に生きているんだからね
現代社会っていうのは
あれからこれ あちらからこちらからとか
あらゆる情報がもうもうもう殺到するというか
もう攻撃しているんです
しかし 何でも入れということではなくて
すごい気をつけた方がいいんです
金だけは幸福ではなく
心の安らぎはより大切なものだと理解する
だから 何か何か仕事をして忙しくするんじゃなくて
心の安らぎこそが一番大事ですよとよく覚えておけば
才能がまた別なケースもありますよ
才能がありすぎる人も落ち着かないが
時々世の中にいますよ
天才みたいな人々はもう才能がありすぎ
その時ももう当然落ち着かないんですよ
もう手に負えない 何か仕事をさせておかないと何するかわからないという危険な人物なんですよ
すごい才能ある人っていうのは結構危険です
で 何の才能もない人はね
やる仕事なかったらね
グーグーと寝てくれるんだから
これでは問題ないんだけど
もう才能抜群の人っていうのは
そうはただでは済みません
自分に才能にあった自分が本当に困るぐらい仕事をやらせてくれないと
それでもこれだったらこの人 1ヶ月間困るぞという仕事を与えても
この連中は 1 日 2 日でやっちゃうんです
これもただもう大変なことになるんですよ
これ あの この才能という言葉というのは現代的な言葉ですけど
昔はあんまりそういう言葉を使わなかったんですよ
これが理解するためにいいエピソードがあるんです
で これエピソードいくつかありますけど
エピソードはもうその同じ論点でできているエピソードっていったって物語なんですよ
で あの 昔は全部労働でしょ
畑仕事でも家の仕事でも
もうすべて労働しか仕事っていうのはないんですよ
畑 自分の手で足でも動いてもう作っても
人間の能力は少ないんだから
そんな特産できません
だから 1 日毎日 1 年中仕事をしても
そんなに穀物はそんなに収入がないんですよ
それでお母さんも仕事をしなくちゃいけない
畑の仕事 それでもお母さんが家のこともしなくちゃいけないし
料理も大変時間かかるし
もうなんだかんだでも
そうするとやっぱりこの才能があればっていう考え方が出てくるんですよ
でも才能という言葉がないんです
で どういうふうに物語を作ったかというと
この鬼ならできると 日本でも似ているエピソードありますよ
そこでもある 呪文 祈祷師じゃなくて呪文ができる
そういう人が まあしょうがない
これで収入も足らん 仕事ももう何て言いますか
間に合わないとかね それで呪文を唱えて唱えて
鬼 1匹捕まるんです 呪力の力で
それでその鬼の頭に何かこの棘みたいなものを刺してつけておくんです
呪文で そうしちゃうと鬼が力がなくなっちゃって
人間の形に 子供の形になるんです
だから見たら鬼ではわからない
もう子供です 子供といっても
まあそれなりの男の子なんです
それでもう男になっちゃったんだから
この祈祷師がこの鬼を連れてくるんです
家に 連れてきて 家内にお前仕事終わったらこいつに頼みなさいと
お手伝いに もう好き勝手に使ってくださいと言うと
まあでも水汲むのは一番難しいことでしょうしね
ではもう本当に助かります
ちょっと水を汲んでこいと
まあ結構距離なんですけど
この子はもうささささといって
家にある全ての水が入れるものがあれば
もう何であろうとも もうたちまち全部水をいっぱい
もうどうしようもない状態で
そこで祈祷師がもう家内に言んで
これ気をつけてくださいと
あの こいつをなんて言いますか
休ませてはいけないんだと
ほんのちょっとでもとにかく仕事をさせておいてくださいと
それでもうじゃあ田んぼの仕事を行こうかと
なんだ 人が 1 日やる仕事はもうほとんど 1 時間で終わっていて
だったらもっと土地を取って
またもう田んぼ仕事をさせると
で  それでまあ結構うまくはいっていたんですけど
まあもうどんどんどうなったかというと
もう で まあ奥さんはもうやっぱりまあ女の人だから
まあこいつはどう見ても男の子で見えるし
まあどうしてももう愛情が湧いてくる
そこを見張ら見張って見計らって
その鬼がさっさと仕事をして
お母さんちょっと疲れたと
寝てもいいと聞くんです
まあいいよと 言ってもお母さんの膝に
もう膝でしたっけ 膝枕
なんて言いますか 膝枕して寝ているお母さん
すごい もうまあよく頑張ってくれる子だなとかね
あんなことはなく で ほんのちょっとで
まあお母さんなんか頭がなんかすごくかゆいんですけど
ちょっと見てくれる？と
言うと いいよと言って頭ちょっと見てあげたんです
見たら何か引っかかってるんですね
何か引っかかってるよと
あ そうか じゃあ抜いてくださいと
と この引っかかってるのを抜いちゃったんです
抜いた途端 もう俺に戻っちゃったんです
そうすると 家にあった奥さんだけではなくて
生きているものは全部殺して食べて
あの あの呪文をかけた人を田んぼにいるんですから
そいつも食べなくちゃと
言って鬼が来るってわかったら
その人はたちまちお参りをしておいたんだと
それでもう違いらないんだから
ではさようならと言って行ったと
言ったら この人たちがやって終わったと
全部言えばもうネズミ 1匹ももう生きてないでしょうと
やっちゃったと 自分が
全部ということで 大変もう嘆く羽目になりましたと
で これは子供は面白がるエピソードなんですけど
子供に言うと おとぎ話ですけど
でおとぎ話の中で結構心理学があるんですよ
みんな忘れてますけど
昔の人っていうのは何のことなく鬼の物語作るんだけど
すごい心理学が入り込んでいるんです
どういう心理学かというと
この才能ありすぎってことなんです
どう見たっても あの男の子はもう人間 100人ぐらいのことできるでしょうに
だからそれ才能でしょ
これありすぎは危ないんだと
我々はそんな才能あるわけじゃないんだけど
でも我々の社会でも時々才能があって
なかなか落ち着かない人々もいる
日本でも結構才能ある人は生まれますけど
大体学校でいろいろやらしちゃって
もう早く自殺して自殺するように追い込むんですね
すごく本当に立派に才能ある
才能あるんだからこそ
もう学校ではうまくいかない
みんなとあんまり仲良くうまくいかない
勉強はまず面白くない
だからって頭が悪いわけじゃないんだけど
テキパキとできる 先生は簡単で言えるべきことというのは
特に日本の先生たちっていうのは
喋る私と同じなんですけど
まあ一言で言えばいいのに
喋るは喋るは喋るは そういうことで
日本の文化っていうのは
主語がはっきりしない
動詞がはっきりしないですからね
それで威張ってますけど
子供にわからないんですよ
はっきりとYES NOで言わないと
脳は曖昧でできてるわけじゃないんですよ
脳っていうのは結構論理的なんです
だからこんなことを聞いていられないんです
私は時々学校の情報なんかを見たり聞いたりするときは
よく思う 自分の感想は
自分が日本で生まれなかったことは良かったと
もし私のガキの頃 あんなこと言っちゃったら
まあ結構やられると思いますよ
ただでは済まない ビシッと論理的に言わないと
自分で直接攻撃できない場合は
もう計画立てる 見事に
ですから この そう思ってしまうのは
ただ私は論理的に考えるからであって
そこまでぐちゃぐちゃ言わなくても
もうさらっと言えばわかるでしょということ
特にその時間イライラするんですよ
子供は だから本当に才能ある子供たちっていうのは結構生まれますよ
だから自分が才能を潰して全く何もできない人になるか
もう自殺してこの社会から逃げようと思うか
どちらかなんですよ だからまあ
これが悪い方向に行っちゃうととても危険なんですよ
例えば この悪いことをやっていると
結構なかなか頭が切れるでしょうに
あるいは自分の能力を悪い方向に持っていっただけのことなんです
どうせこのまとめに仕事をしている人
サラリーマンよりは この不法的なことをやったり
裏でいろんな法律を犯したりやってる
結構頑張ってるし 能力もあるし
才能もあるし 明るいし
もったいないんですよ
で だからこのそういう人々はどうすればいいかというと
有意義なことに忙しくなるのは悪くないんですよ
才能ある人だけはね もうできるだけことをやった方がいいんです
その場合はいろいろ有意義なことを選んで選んでやっちゃえばいいんです
はい それはまあ終わり
はいはい 暇な自分が惨めだと思う
それは分析は他人の目を気にしすぎ
別に暇があって悪くないでしょうに
結局は自分を見ていない
そういう人は自分を見ていない
他人を見ているんです
他人が忙しくて幸せだと勘違いしている
みんな忙しくいるんだからといって幸せだとわからないでしょうに
不幸もあまりに忙しいかもしれませんでしょうに
だからただそれだけ見てわからないでしょうね
だから他人のことを気にしすぎる場合は
自分が惨めに感じちゃうんですね
それで答えは忙しいは幸福という意味ではありません
他人と似たからといって自分が幸福になりません
あの人やっていることをやっているんだと
あの人と同じく私も忙しいんだと
あの人と同じく私も仕事帰りは11時半だよとと言っても
何の意味もないでしょうに
それって幸福って意味じゃないんだから
幸福は他人の基準で決めるものですかと聞きたい
私が聞きたいんです 私の幸福は他の人が決めるんですかね
幸福かないかってのは私の考え方でしょうね
よくも他人に決めてもらうもんもらってるんだから
だから自分を見てないんですよ
自分の時間の余裕を無駄なことに
あるいは自分の時間の余裕を無駄なことに
悪いことに使用していることもある
だから惨めになる 時間の余裕があったら
何か別なね 有意義なことをすればいいでしょうし
そうでな それしない 悪いことばっかりする
例えば 時間があればテレビだけ見ている
パチンコだけやっていると
これは惨めになりますよ
悪いことやっているんだから
ですから 答えは時間を有効にということで
はい まあそれわかったところで9番に行きます
社会が 周りが強引に仕事を押し付けている場合
どうしようかと あの分析はやりたくない
怠けたいという意味なんです
仕事を強引に押し付けてるんだと
私にはと言った途端 意味はやりたくないでしょ
あんた方は強引にあれこれを頼んでるんではないかというと
やりたくないってことははっきりしている
怠けたいっていうこと
で どうすればいいかと
その場合はノーと言える勇気が必要でしょう
強引に仕事を押し付けても
やるべきがないか 自分がやりたいか
やりたくないか これははっきりした方がいいんですよ
どうしよう どうしようと困るんじゃなくて
他人が自分に頼っている場合は
文句言わず 慈しみを持って協力すると幸福感を感じる
よく仕事を頼まれるということは
なんかみんな頼ってるみたいですね
家のお母さんみたいにね
何でもお母さんに言う
みんな一人の人間は子供二人と旦那と
またおばさんとおじいさん
これみんなの面倒見るところ死んだより死んじゃいますよ
しかし これお願いします
あれお願いしますという場合は
なんか自分に頼ってるんですよ
だったらまあ慈しみを持って
まあいいわと文句言わないでね
はい わかりましたということで
全部やっちゃえば ものすごく幸福感感じるんですよ
忙しいと文句言えなくなっちゃうんです
はいはい わかりましたと
すぐやってあげる 無駄なことに余計なことに自分をこき使われていると思うなら断る
例えば旦那さんでも自分が便利な
何て言いますか お手伝いさんやと
そんな調子であれやれ言われたら
もう断った方がいいんです
子供でも母親が便利な道具やと
すぐ注文すれば出してくれる
あの なんて言いますか
ウェンディングマシン
自動販売機 販売機やと
そう思ってあれこれ聞いて言っちゃうと断ればいいんです
ダメやと 例えば子供二人一人がハンバーグを食べたいと
絶対ハンバーグだと 次の子は私はもう何でしたっけ？もうラーメン食べたいんだ
で スパゲティ食べたいんだと
ラーメンは食べないで
子供はね 私はスパゲティ食べたいんだと
はいはい わかりましたと
母が大変苦しいでしょうに
料理 2種類作らなくちゃいかんから
これが自分が自動販売機やという態度で言うならばダメだと
どちらでも作れませんよと
今日はもう魚とこれこれやと嫌なら食べなくてもいいんだよと言えばいいんです
嫌な人は出て行ってくださいと
出て行って勉強してくださいと言えばいいんですよ
そんな勇気も能力も何もないんだから
言ったって無駄ですけどね
そうするの勇力あって子育てするとしっかりしますよ
だから人が頼っているならば
慈しみで仕事をする しかし
気遣われているんだったら断るということ
能力才能がある人には避けられない問題です
それで能力才能があるんだったら
これがもう運命でついてるんだと
決して忙しい暇がないんだと
自分にはことはもう覚悟した方がいいんです
慈しみしかないでしょうね
その場合は  皆様は能力がありすぎちゃって忙しいんだったら
もう答えはないんです
もうしょうがないんです
それだったら いつでも何でも頼まれます
はい 次に行きます 義務
義理 責任があるということで
忙しい人の場合はそれが言い訳になる
見解は間違っている ちょっと考え方おかしい
間違っている で 答え 義理
義務 責任などに文句を言えないのです
文句言える？義理ですけど
やりたくないんだとか
例えば母の面倒見 これは義理なんです
やっぱり母だからやらなくちゃあかんでしょうに
何の文句も成り立たないんですよ
だからこの単語自体おかしいんですよ
単語自体あることさえも
義理 義務 責任とかね そんなのは自然の中で人間やるものでしょうに
これを果たさず生きていられるはずはありません
自分の命に関わりますよ
生きていられなくなります
だから呼吸するのように
この義理 義務や責任というのはやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
呼吸することに誰かが文句言ってますか？なんで一生呼吸しなくちゃあかんかと
誰も文句言わないでしょうに
でも絶えず死ぬまでやっているでしょうに
義理義務も同じことなんです
だから頭がおかしいだけ
そういう人々は 少々考えてみると
生きるということはすべて
すべて義務 義理 責任などだけではないでしょうか
生きてるということは
一切義理 義務 責任だけです
それ以外のものといえば
自分だけの娯楽ぐらいでしょう
義理でも義務でもないのは自分一人の娯楽なんです
自分だけで娯楽だけで娯楽にふけって生活できますかね
気分よく義務 義理 責任などを果たせば良いということ
それはそれだけのこと
文句言えない 成り立たない
はい  11 12 でしたからね
そんなにたくさんないんです
全部追い抜かれたくないというケースは
誰も希望するものではないが
そのように思ってしまうことは自分の弱みを認めることです
追い抜かれたいとは誰も思ってないんですよ
社会に でも追い抜かれたくない
もう負けたらあかんと思っちゃうと
私って本当に弱いと認めているんです
そういう人はいくら踏ん張ってもすでに追い抜かれている
負けている よく覚えてほしいんですよ
もし皆様の心の中でも追い抜かれてはくないと思っちゃうと
もうとっくに追い抜かれているんです
見てください 調べてください
追い抜かれたくないと思った瞬間で
これはなぜそんな気持ちになったのかというと
その見るとあ 追い抜かれているんですよ
負けているんです じゃあどうすればいいかと
社会はライバルだと思うと挑戦できない
だからライバルだと思わないこと
例えば あの自分が長い間会社で仕事をしている
もう年も取っている まあ歳にもなりましたと
そこで新入社員も入りましたと
その人々はもういろいろ電子関係でもう大学も出て
もうなかなかそういう知識的な能力もある
会社に入った途端 何だかんでも全部コンピューターで管理とかね
もう電子的に一切データ管理したりすると
こちらが 1週間  2週間もう徹夜までしてやった仕事っていうのは
この若者がもう何のことなくボタン一つで 2つでもう終わってしまうと
そうしちゃうと もう上の人々も仕事早いんだから
じゃああなた方の仕事でしょうと
では この機械を習ってくださいと言うと
もうもう歳  3歳だからね
もうこんなことはもうできないと思っちゃうでしょうし
それでも若者に負けるってことはなんか惨めで
追い抜かれてこないという気持ちが出てきたりする
もう追い抜かれてるんでしょ
しかし ライバルだと思っちゃうと勉強できないんですよ
どうせもう若者だから
子供みたいに まあまあ
どう君 私に教えてちょうだいよ
おじさんにもと と可愛がって
ライバルじゃなくて まあ自分の子供やと思ってあげれば
すごい元気になって教えてくれるんですよ
これ 教えることっていうのは
大人よりは子供の方がすごい上手なんです
知らないでしょ それが
大体年が下ければ下ほど結構上手に教えるんです
それはまあいいまあ はい
だけど答えは社会はライバルだと思わない
思わない 思うと挑戦できないんだから
能力の発揮もできなくなる
人は自分の精一杯を行って落ち着くべきものです
だから あれこれと追い抜かれたくないとかね
そんなのはどうでもいいんですよ
自分の精一杯やればいいんです
自分のできる範囲の仕事を精一杯やって
あ 私のギリギリはここまでやと
私は精一杯仕事してますよと
若者はでも私のそれは君はそれでも精一杯やってないでしょと言えばいいんです
私のが仕事早いでしょうと
そうかもしれませんだけど
私は精一杯仕事をしている
でも君はそうじゃないでしょうに
言い返しちゃえばそういうもんですよ
追い抜かれたではなくて
追い抜くか抜かれるかではなく
自分の位置にいる これは本当は覚えておった方がいいんですけど
我々は自分の位置にいなくちゃいけないんですよ
ちゃんと ほとんど精神的な問題を作っている人
文句言ってる人は自分の位置に位置をわかってないんです
そちらにいた方がいいんです
別なところに行こうと思っちゃうと結構やられます
はい 次 成功したい 失敗したくないという場合は
まあそれはその通りですね
分析は 別に失敗したい人はいないでしょうね
だから頑張ってください
もう成功したければ しかし
あなたは状況判断もしないでやみくもにやっているだけです
成功したい 失敗したくないと思っちゃうと
なんで当たり前のことを思うんですかね
なんか問題あるんですよ
それでなんで忙しいというんですかね
問題がある 答えは答えではなくて
分析は状況判断していない
やみくもに仕事をしているだけ
頑張っているだけ 失敗する確率だけが目立っています
成功したい 成功したいという人に限って
何が目立つのかというと
失敗することだけすごく目立つんです
その確率は だから成功したいという気持ちはみんな持ってますから
ごちゃごちゃ言うなよと
そんなことは誰でも思ってるんです
だからそんなこと忘れちゃって
状況判断して どう仕事をすればいいかと考えればそれだけの話でしょうね
だから 頭の中に成功と失敗という言葉を入れてはいけませんよ
西洋思考だったらとことん叩いていますけど
そういうのは だから西洋思想的な生き方では
人類はみんな精神病でしょ
東洋思想ではなかったんだからね
でも今 東洋思想はどこにもないんだから
あの中国にしたってもほとんど精神病なんです
だってそういう西洋思考で生きてようとするんだから
頭に成功 失敗なんか入れる単語じゃないんです
状況判断してやればいいってだけで
だから答えは具体的に
論理的に目的を決めて計画を立てて着々と進むことです
成功という言葉は捨てる
こういう目的に達したいと決めて
順番を決めて着々と行く
それだけのことで済みます
忙しいだけはだけとは成功という意味ではありません
成功者には人生の余裕もあるものです
忙しいって言ったら成功者っていう意味じゃないんですよ
本当は成功者には結構余裕があるんですよ
人生に いろいろ日本でも結構本できてますよ
この成功者のね 時間の使い方やら何だらかんだらとかね
かなり欲を煽る本ばっかりなんですけど
そんな人のことを真似たら大失敗しますからね
結局はね 自分が自分だから
それでもすごい私の本よりは読み応えがあって面白い
読みもう楽しいと思います
読んでみてください で
何がわかるかというと
ものすごい大会社を作ったりして
大サイバースと何とか何とかね
そういう人々には結構時間の余裕があるんですよ
何がそれ？と 忙しくないんです
だから成功者っていうのは忙しいとは文句言わないんです
だから目的を作って着々と進んでいくだけの話です
それで俗世間で忙しいという 12 の項目
何か抜けてるならば もう今のうち手を挙げて言ってください
12 以外 13 もありますよとかね
14 もありますよとか
してください 貧乏暇なしという言葉がありますね
これは適していることわざです
暇がないんだ 貧乏人だから失敗者であることは明らかです
だから忙しいでしょ 忙しいって言ったらもう貧乏に決まってるんです
だから貧乏暇なしなんです
だから忙しいイコールはもう人生は失敗っていうことなんです
だから成功者には余裕があるんです
そんなところかな 次のスライド見てみましょうか
映してみてください はい
これから仏教編に入りますので
一旦休憩いたします